[Music]
[Applause]
what a laden today I'm joined by one of
Scotland's finest Lads you'll ever meet
he's played rugby all around the world
including 137 games for Edinburgh he
played over 50 in the UK for Gloucester
he played over 50 in France for clemont
and he's played plenty for The Shining
arcs in Japan not only that he's also
kept in his country more than any other
player and it's the second top Point
scorer for his beloved Scotland and also
he's recently just called time on his
very special rugby career so there's no
better time to get this led on he is the
absolute Champion lad himself Greg
Laidlaw welcome mate
there we go yeah thanks for coming on
yeah no that's a pleasure to join you
and uh yeah as I said it's um yeah
greatly good to be on and uh looking
forward to the chat mate stoked heavy on
like everyone I've spoken to about you
has pretty much said like oh what a lad
he is you need to get him on the podcast
as soon as you can so great to finally
get you
yeah it's great to be here
um and uh yeah I'm in front of them so
here in Japan uh currently at the moment
I'm staying on a little bit longer most
of the foreign Lads now I've shot off
the back home but I've got two of my
kids are in school over here so we
decided to stay for another month and
keep them in school fair enough how old
are your kids
um you've got three boys eight six and
the little man's only nine months so uh
still in the midst of the the tough
stuff uh as well as coming out of the
woods of earth right yeah how they all
found Japan oh man they've done really
well huh like
about my oldest is like he's pretty full
on uh like a lot of the loves his sport
and stuff uh he's pretty competitive so
I wonder where he got that but yeah
they've done real well and it's honestly
been it's been a really opener for uh
both Rachel my wife and myself
um our oldest he's speaking like
Japanese
um and stuff like that man so it's it's
awesome to see kids are truly amazing
yeah it is crazy they're just way better
than us don't they yeah they do they
just sort of get on with it and you know
the Japanese friends and one obviously
yeah they don't seem to buy an eyelid
which is great yeah and how are you
feeling obviously you've you've called
time on on your career footy is done how
are you feeling about all that
uh relief I recognize yeah yeah it's
it's kind of been on my mind for a long
time
um and I think obviously when I've seen
in Japan I knew it was probably going to
end up you know I finished my career
over here anyway but
I was having real thoughts about it
before we even started this season and I
wasn't really sure I wanted to play
um so it's more relief than I've
definitely been ready for an enormous
ready for the next sort of Step you know
in in my in my life in in many ways as
well as my sort of professional career
and I'm actually I'm along with a
clubhouse now which is a couple of
minutes from my house and already
there's a couple of boys you know
downstairs and they've been doing a bit
of running and stuff and I'm just like
yeah thank goodness I do not need to do
that anymore
how is your body is your body sweet or
is it just mentally just feel like
you're done no my body's all right
um I'll get my odd aches and pains like
like everybody that's played uh Pro
rugby or any rugby for a stranger thing
my bike mainly been the the biggest
issue but more mentally you may I think
it just it comes to the point like I
don't mind the games and stuff this year
I quite enjoyed the games and playing
but it's everything in between you know
from you know pre-season way to as
you'll know it when you're coming to
them and you start thinking about that
stuff more than you know more than the
rugby itself you you know that your
time's coming to an end yeah and
especially in Japan Acres preseason's
longer than or like four times longer
than the season it's pretty much all
training and you don't get too many
games at at the end of it no you don't
you don't get that the sort of good part
of the Ender or certainly for an
extended period of attainment uh we've
got pumped this season and preseason as
well like down in like we went there and
stayed with someone like in the heat end
of August September and I'm just
thinking thank goodness this is the last
time I'm gonna have to do this
you know a lot of people went even when
their body's feeling okay you get to the
end and you get another contract in
front of you you see all the numbers you
see the year
oh do I go one more but you you didn't
get there you weren't tempted to go one
more you'd had enough completely I've
had enough here like Mama my agent and
stuff over here as well I was like oh
you should you know keep playing you're
playing well and I was like look man I'm
I'm I've made peace for this I'm ready
for the next thing uh and I'm done yeah
fair enough it sounds like you guys have
to do a thousand malcolms or something
oh titty black was saying you're right
into them
well I'm not because I'm so close to the
government I can get done any Donuts
around I'm all good with that stuff but
anything to do with a walkway and
lifting heavy weights well sounded like
probably me and thoughts
uh classic and how did you find like the
lifestyle in Japan you sort of touched
on it but I'd imagine you would have
adapted pretty well um you look like
you'd be a good Onsen man one cents are
good man but um oh we're we're quite
lucky we're best
um with NTT we're kind of
and talk your beer so we're kind of
stuck out of the way a little bit so it
wouldn't be like hugely busy uh but uh
they made the cultures it's it's awesome
uh you know people are they've got a lot
of respect anybody that's traveled to
Japan or sort of know that and then
that's probably some of the stuff that's
certainly been lost a little bit
internally back back in the UK I reckon
and stuff like that so I love that
aspect of it and you know we talked
about kids uh briefly early on that it's
real safe for the kids and stuff when we
first got here so there was a there's
loads of young kids right wandering
about on their own and walking to the
school bus and my wife and I were kind
of looking at each other like what is
happening here where where's all the
grown-ups where's all the parents
um but that's just how it is you know
it's it's so safe the kids you know from
five six year old they kind of just cut
about and get on the trains get on buses
on their own it's fairly incredible yeah
it is crazy and what's been the hardest
thing to sort of adapt to what are you
looking forward to getting back to
Scotland and and having or being able to
do again it's definitely a language made
that's probably the most difficult thing
and not so much here at the club because
it sounded like this club we've got two
full-time transfers so in terms of rugby
stuff it's pretty easy but everyday life
that can be a tough challenge whether
that's yeah you're going to the bank or
the supermarket or you know where you
know you're going to take one of the
kids to the doctor or whatever it's they
can be tough work man there's some days
you think uh let's just throw the towel
in and move back to Scotland with it you
don't of any of these hustles you know
yeah I remember when you first moved
over there it's just overwhelming at
everything like the doctor trying to set
up your car your infinite even going to
the supermarket for the first time it's
just so overwhelming you're not sure
what the hell is going on no man it's
tougher man you have to do any of their
trips to like city hall or anything like
Ahmed to do yeah residence cards and um
like standing in lanes for 30-40 minutes
and you've no idea what's happening well
it's good times yeah they don't mind a
cure hey they love they love lining up
even if they're not sure what it's for
they do not mind the queue
they do not mind the queue where was I
rather I was somewhere where the hell
are they there and we were like there
was this ridiculous queue and I just I
said to my wife I said we're not
standing here I'm out of here
it's like if you go along because we're
only one stop from uh like Disneyland
Disneyland Tokyo yeah you go along there
and it's absolute chaos yeah it's like
the longer the queue the more likely out
they are to line up they just they love
standing in them yeah they don't seem to
mind like I don't know if it's a
cultural thing or a respect thing but
there's no issues at all like you're
talking a good couple of hours when you
go along to Disneyland so yeah yeah fair
play to them but it's not for me no not
for me not uh not at all but so the next
move for you is to move back to Scotland
have you got um plans on what you're
gonna do gonna get into the coaching I'd
imagine you'd be a wizard like your
cousin bro well yeah my cousin's done a
good job to referral yeah which is great
to see but so I'm I'm signed on for for
actually uh next season out here in
terms of I'm gonna go straight into the
staff with the same team oh that's right
awesome uh yeah on the coaching side so
um yeah that's I've had a sort of not
abundant desire but that's been I love
the game mate
um and it's been something I've I've
thought about long and hard and you know
I essentially that's what I forged my
career is you know for that speed of
thought and you know I was I was never
the quickest I'd leave it I was always
pretty quick in the top two inches
thankfully for me so yeah I've always
enjoyed that sort of side of the game
and and getting the best out of people
and also a couple of different avenues
like that sort of leadership
performance Under Pressure a lot of
stuff really sort of intrigues me so
yeah short term or
um we're going to stay in Japan one more
season and then I'll see what happens
after that right how does that what role
exactly will you be doing
so I'm I'm going to be down as an
assistant coach
um I'm gonna be working with a defense
coach for the most part there's a couple
of guys that look after the attack here
so I'll
and I'll do the defense alongside him
I've actually done a better player
coaching this year I took charge of the
Box defense uh here anyway this year so
I sort of had a not one foot in each cam
but I was I was making that progression
that would have been hard without any in
your line
well he was one of the good guys Matt he
just chops people down and gets over
there
now he's emailed my life nice and easy
he's been good to walk with uh he's a
good man so uh and then I'll probably
I'm hoping to do a fair bit of the
skills as well I reckon
um
we need to assembly the team uh the
armor we need to upscale a fair bit of
hopefully a lot of ideas that can really
help and around that and I'm hoping it's
a good place to start my sort of
coaching Journey because where the
Japanese guys as you probably know me
they're you know they're awesome in
terms of like the work ethic and stuff
but yeah you know sometimes they just
don't know almost with the channel that
energy so you know hopefully I can help
on that front yeah and and then what's
the dream for you like where do you see
coaching taking is it like an
international gig with Scotland or
um following your brother to potentially
a Super Rugby team over the next few
years
oh listen I think oh my heart yeah my
heart will definitely tell you I'd love
to coach you know Scotland one day but
yeah yeah that's a long way off
obviously I think you know I'm a big
believer you've got to go and down your
stripes you know elsewhere and and those
types as a coach clearly you know if
you've been a half decent players it
doesn't automatically qualify you you're
going to be a great coach so yeah go
away you know learn as much as I can
work hard
um I think that experience thing
um is massive so you know working in in
different countries whether that's you
know New Zealand or you know Aussie
somewhere like that I think you know
someday like you know Clark uh landlord
is my cousin for that it doesn't always
came down New Zealand a fair few number
of years ago now I couldn't tell you how
many uh you know he's done a great job
and I know he loves it down there and I
actually was I caught up with them uh
just a couple of months back there in
Hong Kong I went down to to Hong Kong
seven so with NTT here and you know I
was able to catch up with Clarke and it
would be able to squeeze in a couple of
beers as well which was quite nice right
I could imagine you two and Hong Kong
together would have been an absolute
nightmare
yeah he was he was a lot worse than me
I'll tell you that much which I was
surprised
[Laughter]
anyway one thing I do always like to do
is um sort of go through the guest
Journey from the start and we've had a
few Scottish Lads on uh Finlay Christie
um Scott Steele obviously your cousin
clarky but
um I do like to would like to hear your
story mate from the start what was it
what were you like as a wee Scottish
Lair growing up uh
it was pretty much
like no computers for ourselves for sure
everything was outside uh any any ball
we'd get a hold of you know rugby balls
footballs tennis golf we played a lot uh
that mainly you know we were pretty
Clark and Clark's Brother Scott a little
bit older than me but I'd scrap about
them uh for a little bit and then Clark
and Scott have got a younger brother
Chris who's even younger than me so
quite a big age Gap and I was closer to
him so I've spent a fair bit of time
with him as well but yeah so we grew up
in a small town called jedra down in the
Scottish war of borders it's only about
4 000 people I think at the time when I
was growing up so not a huge amount
happening mate don't know apart from uh
you know playing a bit of footy and then
at that time it was like I guess it was
time to change then even but
traditionally that was like rugby
Heartland in Scotland you know it's a
sort of working class uh you know part
of the world and that was you know very
much a big sort of of the Q a
um you know down down there in Jared so
yeah I mean that's that's really where
it started
um my dad was a big part of that he was
my first coach there in the mini rugby
there and then you know essentially just
just progressed from there were you good
were you a good player at a young age
you obviously
um competitive and by all accounts into
everything but were you were you a
Goodwill player
yeah I'm obviously you know I think I
had you know something about me I think
you know certainly wasn't anywhere near
being the finished article uh in my
early days I'll probably always like
that top end speed uh you know which is
you know would sadly for me which would
have been lovely as you love it that
always helps but so I'll probably figure
that out at quite a young age and so I
thought you know I'm gonna have to if
I'm gonna go all the way out I need a
sort of point of difference so that's
gonna have to be you know skill sets uh
you know uh getting stuck in uh you know
being smarter in the game as well so I
was sort of I was able to
from a really young age which I guess
you know really helped me come to come
the back end yeah what age do you think
if you felt like that like you could
control a game with you know the top top
two inches
yeah and I think once I've probably
started pushing through into the
Edinburgh team I guess oh yeah I was up
Edinburgh for a couple of Seasons before
I got any you know great amount of game
time and
I ended up playing for a club team up in
Edinburgh as well and I actually played
a fair bit of rugby uh r10 as well oh
yeah yeah I think which would I think I
reckon that's helped me in over the
years and just uh you know
appreciation I guess in many ways you
know what's it like to be one channel
further out and you know what's
happening and what can help minds and
vice versa so I reckon it sort of stand
from there and and obviously people
around about you may as well as you'll
know from from your career is such a
huge influence certainly when you're in
the younger days you're coming out of
the academy and I had um Chris Patterson
at the time at Edinburgh uh you know
over 100 caps for Scotland and and he
was in many ways probably ahead of his
time you know he's really professional
you know great goal kicker and somebody
that you know really uh spent time and
energy on his craft and and then also
something like Mike Blair as well who's
he was a great halfbacker Edinburgh
played a lot of times for Scotland and
British and Irish lines so I was able to
sort of or I was willing to you know
learn and understand you know of these
types of players which really helped me
massively and were you always a goal
kicker like was it did you start that at
a young age yeah I did I don't know
where that's what I came from I think I
just enjoyed it yeah you know when I was
younger you know get a tea and it was
probably boredom a lot of times maybe
just get yourself along the the closest
field you'll bang if he goes over and
it's it's stood me in pretty good stead
yeah obviously it's been a big part of
your career all the way through so that
ability to kick goals and kick them
under pressure because obviously you've
kept some massive ones throughout your
journey yeah I mean it's yeah it's it's
tough it's tough work as well it's you
know people always say yes you know you
look so calm and this and that and you
know I'm not so sure I felt like that
for the most part you know you talk
about that relief finishing up your
career and stuff that's certainly a part
of it I'm not gonna miss I'm not gonna
lie
I would have thought the opposite
because you were always you're right you
always did look so confident um lining
up a kick and and you got them more
often than not so um it's interesting to
hear that you weren't always that
confident learning oh well I mean
whether I was I'm not saying I wasn't
confident but I think I had confidence
in myself
through through a process I guess I came
to came to develop because I think you
know that talked a bit a little bit
about performance under pressure and for
me you know it comes back to the process
and you know all the things that you
know staying in the moment so I came up
with a system essentially I had and you
know I worked out over time and a few
keywords I would say to myself and
essentially that I came my kicking
routine and they're not essentially
you had to block everything else out and
get another routine and and go through
with it and I was I guess that's the
part of mental strength you need to be a
really good goal kicker in my opinion
mate oh there's a good bit of advice for
any goal kickers out there nice and
early anyone listening to that go kick
some girls with that that is that is
some good stuff but did you ever feel
like um your size was ever going to hold
you back obviously at most little guys
get told at some point in their career
that they're going to be too small to
make it as a professional footy player
have you got any stories like that
yeah around
I was sort of trying to push through an
Edinburgh team in my younger days and
you know I would always get you'd always
do the gym like with the team and stuff
um training and I'd get sent back into
the gym uh pretty much after training to
you know I had to go and do extra
weights or whatever and oh you've got to
get bigger you've got to get stronger
and yeah potentially I had to get
stronger and I get certainly when I was
coming through I was it wasn't my
younger days but you know
professionalism had been about for a
fair bit but I probably didn't take it
outside of it too seriously right at the
very start uh and sell in terms of the
German stuff you know I'll just well I
just love playing rugby and I was like
oh I've got to do this sort of gem stuff
on the side as well so but I think again
we talked about people that influence
you and stuff and you know if you're in
a good system and you sort of realize
that I write that this is actually part
of the job and yeah I have to actually
make some make some gains in this sort
of part of it as well and you pick up
cute things of of coaches throughout the
years man that's that's what I've always
found I think you know some coaches
aren't great but you know a lot of times
you can still pick things up with them
and
um you know Scott Johnson was quite big
on that side of the game as well in
terms of you know your strength work
your speed work as well and always sort
of remember him he pushed me quite hard
in that area as well which which I do
think would really helped me in the end
also so how did you get your first crack
with Edinburgh like what was your
pathway to the to the top team
um again I think we've picked up a
couple of injuries because we had I
talked about Mike Blair before and he
was sort of starting Scotland or
halfback at the time really good player
and
um I think it was Phil Goodman he he
played 10 and he got injured and we
never had too too much sort of strength
and depth and I was a half decent uh you
know rugby player so the next minute I
sort of get pushed into that 10 Rule and
it was almost you know a case of you
getting our sort of best players on the
field at one point yeah
um so that was kind of have a sort of
force more in and really and then sort
of kept my kept my place in that sort of
10 Jersey
um for a sort of couple of Seasons it
wasn't then and then eventually sort of
moved them into nine I think uh Mike was
Michael's still at the club and then
Mike played our played and then and then
Mike eventually moved on and I sort of
uh you know progressed into that slot
but we had a great run that one of the
years I played 10 we made it to the
semis of the European Cup uh yeah the
Champions cuppers and we were a small
team in in comparison
um we had like Ross and Metro you know
and our pool as it wasn't and they did
it it was like four teams in the pool
the old school one yeah and so it was
tough walk but we we beat them both home
and away
um and then we lost the Ulster over in
the Aviva stadium London Road in the
semi-final they're not by not by many
points uh so yeah some great memories
looking back to that right the Glory
Days and you obviously probably had a
few
um Scottish kiwis over there playing for
you at the time any anyone that you're a
member or any good stories about any of
those lads
um but I don't I can't remember right at
the start of it too many killer kiwis as
I've known in the Scotland South but
tell who was there man I actually spoke
to them or there was it was Benny
artinga I'm sure I'm sure on my Edge a
little bit now but
um Benny I was ashamed because Benny his
body was pretty busted up late but I
could tell by watching this guy is like
oh crikey this boy's got a bit about him
yeah and to be fair to Benny like you
worked his socks off and he actually got
himself in a really good neck
I think it was going into the second
year and a sad legal injured again and
he never played too much but yeah he was
probably one of the one of the sort of
flash guys
um I came across and then boys in the
actual Scotland team that I've played
with I was thinking about this earlier's
probably Shawnee Maitland oh yeah uh
Sean is a great guy yeah I really
enjoyed you know spending time with him
he's real real laid back yeah and then
another one would be uh the hard sauce
May John Hardy John Hardy surely you've
got some hot sauce yeah and she's what a
character from there he's a character of
the hardware I remember I remember once
a minute it was like I think it was
after a Scotland test and we went back
to the hotel and I think we you know it
was like really large we've got another
test and I think it must have been the
following week so it was like come down
to the team and we'll have a couple of
beers and uh you know that'll be it sort
of thing next minute like hearts appears
and he's like sitting there with us
suspicious little big jug which
obviously looked like what a nice but
she told the doctors yeah it's just like
I used to warm it and obviously he's
sitting drinking like I think it was
like gin and tonic or something like
that he's getting charged at that man
having a few but yeah he's certainly a
great
yeah so then how did you get your crack
at Scotland um obviously you're playing
well for Edinburgh was it after that
successful year with Edinburgh where you
guide them to the semi-final that you
get the call up yeah I mean it was
pretty much off the back of that so
we had Andy Robinson as as head coach
and mother the former England uh forward
scorch he was a really good coach uh
actually uh uh he was somebody I learned
a lot of
uh a lot about the game off uh so when
he came into Edinburgh and then he he
done a really good job Edinburgh I think
we finished second in the league and he
took on the Scotland job uh off the off
the back of that so it was kind of well
organically I guess you know he'd walk
with me
um Edinburgh you know I was still
playing
um half decent edin run and I sort of
made that transition into the into the
Scotland Squad and and eventually you
know pushed into the team from there man
talk to me about what it's like um
playing for Scotland obviously um mate I
loved an issue with them the passion you
guys think that with his uh Next Level
and sold out murrayfield
um talk to me about what it's like
playing the air in front of a sold out
Stadium oh man there's nothing better
for a you know a passionate Scotsman
like myself and I'd be real patriotic
and I think
I'll take you sort of into March day
like March day in murrayfield is really
special because you normally Edmond's
not a big city so you end up sort of
driving through the heart of the city on
the team bus and you can almost feel and
sense the atmosphere on the way to the
stadium normally it's pissing around as
well but
um you know that's just that's just part
of the pockets when you come to
murrayfield
um and then he's yeah I listen all the
fans are like you know close to the bus
and then when you arrive at the stadium
you normally get you get piped around by
by the bagpipes and it's obviously like
culturally so that's a big part for us
as well and I think
um and I think the Scottish people are
they are really passionate about the
sport obviously I love winning like
everybody does that's sometimes that's
tough you know playing for Scotland
um but that's just the way it is man
it's it's so special to to run out of
money field so special to have been able
to cut Captain Scotland
um you know over my career as well it's
such a privilege for me uh you know all
I wanted to do you know was win and and
do a good job of leading the boys so
yeah great memories looking back some
tough ones as well but that again that's
that's just part of playing for Scotland
there but essentially but we're a small
country uh yeah in my opinion it is a
fairly good job for most of the thing
yeah definitely and you mentioned
captaincy how did that um role come in
we did you always feel like you're a
captain or
um how did the opportunity to Captain
your country come about
okay I don't know if I ever like felt
you know like I'm like a captain sort of
material I'm like ma sort of mannerism
I'd be fairly introverted uh you know
for the most part of it
but I think I've always been really
driven and I think that's probably you
know where it really came for from and
that sort of will to succeeded the will
to win I I don't I don't like getting
beaten and beating so I think it kind of
can stemmed from there essentially and
you know I think that connection with my
with my teammates about you know driving
my teammates forward or trying to to
make everybody better not just myself
you know I think that's where they came
from and I was always like willing to
challenge I guess and you know it always
it came from the right place you know
and certainly my my younger days maybe
that didn't come across uh the right way
but like everybody asked me I'm sure
you'll be the same and you maybe melon I
feel a bit over the years but certainly
my younger years are suddenly I wasn't
uh scale to challenging people in China
away from that oh mate what a captain
you sound like were you were you someone
who was always um getting into sort of
biffo on the training field I feel like
you're competitiveness would always be
winding people up on the training field
or getting ending up in scaffolds or
stuff
oh there was um there's a couple over
the years man but I mean you know I like
to be the sort of a train and heal that
that was for sure I was never one of
them but yeah oh there was always it was
a couple of moments there's a couple of
moments with FedEx over the years yeah I
mean because he's like with with two
different people uh that's that's
probably I reckon that's probably why we
got on so well you know but you know
straight away after training with you
know he'd normally just take a piss out
of me and tell me I was pretty grumpy
but yeah that's it normally how it would
end up and would laugh it off but our
fin was so laid back you know and
sometimes you know tell him when he
first came out of that that set up I
would find it quite difficult to take
you know I don't want to you know sort
of keep the pump and I'm keeping on the
pressure to perform and because you're
he's in such a pivotal role but
obviously I've come to learn he's such a
great talent and
um over the years yeah we had some good
fun so what does that look like when is
this when he's trying to make a play
when it's not on and then you're just
absolutely spraying them or what's it
sort of look like yeah that's not the
hoe that went but would be trying like
something absolutely ridiculous and he
totally just shrug it off and on um
here's me I'm trying to drive standards
and tell everybody else what to do but
as you'll know about that's that's the
beauty about leadership it's you know
some people you've gotta you've just
gotta let them go and go down that path
and and other people eat you know will
actually show them love or you give them
a kick up last you've got to find that
balance yeah right 100 oh what a captain
but it talks to me about the Six Nations
obviously a competition we don't get to
see too much of over here but at the
moment I've been I've been loving
watching the quality of the Six Nations
[__] it's a good competition now what's
it like playing in it obviously five
tough games
um no finals it's just weekend week out
just into it
it's it's awesome it's an awesome uh
awesome experience I reckon if anybody's
like not been not been down to it or not
experienced it
um you know from the Southern Hemisphere
or whatever you know I'd really say get
yourselves up come and have a look and
experience it in person if he can't
because I think it's it's epic in terms
of just the the different atmospheres
you go to whether that's you know
Scotland traveling down to Wales and
there's Mayors like rugby clubs up and
down the country that you know they're
jumping on buses and so on buses and
driving yeah you know seven eight hours
I don't know Wales and and what have you
so I think it's as much as it's it's
about the rugby and the whole
uh
the whole spectacle of all and the
history I think it's it's also about the
other side as well it's about people
going down you know they'll have you
know Scotsman of friends down in Wales
from over years or over an island it's
it's the catching up it's it's the game
day experience and I think it's really
unique in
um in the rivalries are only seem to be
getting bigger at the moment in time
because the rugby has been so tight as
well yeah yeah and that's and it's great
to see like likes of France coming back
to the party as well and like they used
to be years ago and and the games are so
tight and it's almost
you know actually I've made some gains
as well which it's great to see but I
think anybody else at the moment I think
just about anybody can can win the comp
as well which makes it so exciting yeah
mate um Netflix documentary is going to
be a real interesting one um watching it
from behind the scenes shame shame it
wasn't done a couple of years earlier
and we could witness your captaincy on
the big screen
yeah I mean that's that will be
interesting when it comes out um again
as I sort of said before like sort of
introvert saying to me I'll potentially
been a bit bit worried about it
um and I know there's a there's a fair
bit of a sort of blowback I believe you
know
I think from a few teams you know
obviously Island and well everybody
essentially you know Ireland have
they're going well number one team in
the world have you know aspirations to
go and win the world cup and they're
saying you know what's going on here you
know there's people coming behind the
scenes a year out from the World Cup and
I think because you know Andy Farrell
was saying that and then obviously it
won the final England he's saying well
if they're not doing it we're not doing
it and yeah uh so but I think they got
most of it over the line and I think
it's hopefully it's a really good thing
for the game and it's going to grow the
game and you know without getting too
far behind the scenes and obviously
laying away Secrets uh I guess that's
what everybody's you know worried about
but I mean I don't know what's like you
know because you like down in New
Zealand you'll be able to tell me more
it's like you know you kiwi guys you
seem to be you're pretty open that's
certainly what I've found here in over
the years and uh you know I don't always
like to say the Kiwi teams that they'd
be open to something like that as well
like going forward do you reckon yeah
we've actually got a like a documentary
crew filming the Crusaders at the moment
just behind the scenes but there's still
it's still a little bit like you guys uh
or like the Irish and English everyone's
sort of you know looking over their
shoulder what what are you actually
filming here what are you gonna take out
of it so um we're not there yet but it's
gonna get there like sooner rather than
later like it's gonna be it's gonna be
the normal you've seen the success that
like the Formula One and stuff I've had
from then Netflix documentaries so
um yeah it's gonna happen it's just once
everyone starts to getting a bit more
comfortable with it all and Trust what's
actually going on and what it's actually
yeah
that's the big one isn't it it's like
trust and I think the when the Netflix
stuff was all sort of coming in the same
contracts I don't think they had like uh
any power to like do anyway editing or
anything like that they wanted what was
going to be yeah get insured so but
they'll do it in the right way because
all the all the other ones you know
they've been epic whether it's a Formula
One or the tennis and I think for sports
fans it gives you a great insight to
actually you know what goes into you
know what you see on whether it's race
day or March day and a huge amount of
work that goes on behind the scenes yeah
100 looking forward to watching it but
talk to me about the um two Rugby World
Cups you obviously got to get to go to
got to go to both of them um one in the
UK one in Japan
um obviously the one in the UK uh didn't
probably finish how you like want to
talk to me around that World Cup for you
and what what you remember about it I
remember we had a great time together
um that was that was my sort of abide in
memory of like
the team ship I think everybody was on
the same page
yeah I would like a real good connection
again sort of going through the team
something I was really big on as well
and we were really lucky we were able to
work with uh with Owen Eastwood
um yeah he probably had the one and uh
you know that whole thing around uh you
know connections your sort of belongings
uh so I really enjoyed that sort of part
of it
um and then getting more into the rugby
it's uh I think we've played well for
the most part uh but you know the big
one around 2015 is uh I've been asked a
lot of times about is obviously the the
quarter final uh I get against the
Aussies and yeah it was funny actually
because just last week I've done a
little thing here in Japan with with
Will gainian
um and Mark ghetto as well oh yeah who
would also they were sort of winding me
up and saying it doesn't matter we had
we had different opportunities to win
the game animated yeah but yeah it was a
certainly a strange one and one that I
do think about every now and again yeah
so what actually happened for the for
the listeners don't remember the moment
talk me through it from your from your
voice yeah you'll obviously right in the
mix yeah
I couldn't maybe he was off the field
that quickly I couldn't
uh so we were winning the game yeah it
wasn't long after like a couple of
minutes tops and uh we had a line out
and uh there was an overthrow and
we've somebody's touched it from a
Scottish side and then you know one of
the Scottish boys has been in front of
the boys end up it's one of their ones
that's fell straight into the Bread
Basket and he's just caught it but ended
up giving a penalty away but what's
actually happened is one of the Aussie
boys has touched it before the other
players caught it so I think it should
have been a scrum to Australia and
obviously we had a sort of chance to
defend uh our lead with a couple of
minutes left but as it were uh Craig
duberty he offered a I wanted a penalty
to Australia and credit to bear on Floyd
I think it was he he knocked over a nice
kick and uh yeah we couldn't rent them
in from there so the rest is history as
I said right you would have begged
yourself to hold them out for those last
two minutes if he awarded the scrum oh I
got a smell in it yeah I think it was it
was one of the games that was such a big
uh it was such a big momentum shift like
in the game we picked up I am like an
intercept and stuff and uh you could
almost tell her that the Aussie boys are
like were going on but they we give them
an opportunity with the penalty and the
the rest is history as they're saying
uh crazy about sort of you know you sort
of run off the field but anyway that's
not seen ever Sean I'm sure most people
have there's one of the ones of it is
what it is though you can't what can you
do I don't know not very much
yeah mate just reminisce about the times
you went so close which could have been
you guys in the final really against the
All Blacks and who knows you might have
won that one yeah but I want to know
definitely different story
[Laughter]
and then what about the um World Cup in
Japan
I was great from like something
completely different you know in terms
of you know the game and rather than
just whether it's playing in Europe or
you know whatever Aussie or New Zealand
I think it was it was great for the you
know different country to take on
I think we never played well at all uh
there's probably a couple of different
reasons around that so it's it's always
hard because you know first and foremost
you're going there to do a job and you
know the good times off the field yeah
and they sort of fall into place after
your job on the field so it's always a
difficult one and
not at all we we came out here quite
early
um we were based down in Nagasaki
um and whether that was you know we're
trained obviously down there in the heat
we pushed ourselves pretty hard
whether it was too hard uh you know
that's potentially it was because we
just never fired any shots you know we
just we're never going at all against
Ireland and the first game well beaten
uh beat Samoa and then obviously for for
the people that you know were watching
that Japan had a sort of a lot of
momentum you know behind them in that
competition and they'd be island as well
so you know it's full credit to to Japan
and they beat us on the day as well and
again we just never really fired any
shots or maybe a little bit unsure of
you know who what is a team at that
point in time and yeah so it was a
difficult one to take because obviously
I knew I was I was going to finish up
after that World Cup as well uh my sort
of time had come to an end and I was
Keen to move on to a mixed sort of
challenge so yeah it was a difficult one
for me to take personally but you know
hopefully you know there's some boys
that are left in our Squad now heading
into the World Cup this year in France
and you know hopefully the team are in a
better sport mentally and uh they can
all can go on the same page and because
they're going to have to they're on a
very tough pool again this time around
yeah oh that's a shame no fairy tale
finish but was there was there a game
that was post or canceled which cost you
something around that or did you guys
not get to play a game or what happened
there no no yeah it was it was a close
one so what happened was
there was a there was a typhoon coming
in
um before before we pledged upon so it
was it was coming in there I think yeah
I think we were playing on the Saturday
I think it was we were playing and the
typhoon was like coming in on the Friday
at some point that's right
um so we were sort of hold up another
tower for the hall there so obviously
traditionally like you you do your team
run captains on the day before so Mary
was literally locked down in a hotel you
know there's things coming hit whatever
so if it's if it stays around till the
Saturday obviously we can't play so if
it passes through quickly potentially we
can still play the game so we ended up
doing like captains on walking through
in the in the hotel in the team room and
so it was and we never knew the game was
on until the morning of the game it was
yeah but it was it was a bizarre it was
a bizarre setup as well and I wasn't
actually Captain uh of That World Cup
fighter uh but then Greg had asked me to
Captain our game as well so yeah it was
it was a difficult one it was different
one for me personally uh on for whatever
reason for for the team as well so
hopefully they can land me and move on
be interesting and you mentioned uh the
World Cup this year how do you think um
Scotland are going to go it's obviously
like you said such a close
um competition when you look at it like
there's so many teams that could win it
on paper who are you sort of predicting
and were you thinking Scotland are going
to finish
oh man
school I'm gonna have to play really
well
um probably well twice would be really
good
um you know but definitely once they're
gonna have to play you know to the full
potential you know to either tip over an
island or tip over to South Africa but
essentially go the pool are definitely
gonna have to win one of them so
yeah tonga's in hapoo as well and so and
they've got some free cash players in
there as well I mean I think Scott I'll
have too much because they've been
together a long time they've got a
better cohesion in the group box
the the Scotland have got some real
powerful players some strike Runners
whether it's Duran Vander merva uh it's
the only two pilotu there in the
Midfield that I've sort of really came
in and I guess complemented some of the
other players we've got and their
friends Hoagies
and Blair King horse done a good job as
well he's been dangerous when he's been
coming on so I think now we've got
enough Firepower uh if we don't get any
injuries we've got to get some luck
around that don't get any injuries and
then really perform you know when Mrs
that last World Cup we've never done
that we performed poorly when we needed
to perform so you know the boys I guess
have gotta that's the challenge for them
this time around you know when that when
it kicks off against South Africa for
like 80 minutes you've got to perform to
the potential and they've got to tip one
of their teams to get out of the pool
yeah that is a brutal pull that is a
tough one so who are you expecting to be
the hardest to be in the whole
competition who's your money on
um now I reckon Australia I've got a
good chance do you sure yeah well I do
because yeah because they're in the
right side of the draw uh for starters I
mean I don't think there's ever been a
World Cup draw so I saw in balance
and I think you you look at like the
consecutive amount of games you're gonna
have to get up on whether that's you
know you look at France or New Zealand
uh you know South Africa Island whoever
he's gonna have to win a lot of games
against a lot of good teams whether
that's right I don't see the drawer like
they've not got that as much so they're
gonna have to like really perform what
twice three times and you know on the
other side of the draw that that figure
is almost doubled so it's yeah you know
and I think something that Eddie Jones
has done well over the years is that
it's like that shock and all [__] that
isn't it he comes in he gets people
going pretty quickly in the right
direction I think he's he's obviously
real about Australia and I think
similar to Scotland there's many in many
ways Australia if they get a bit of luck
around injuries you know they get
everybody fit at the right time I think
they can be a dangerous team as well
mate I wouldn't have picked that the
Aussies to win the Rugby World Cup you
hit it here first yeah well we'll see I
just think there's there's a few sort of
stars aligning for a moment yeah the the
needle a little bit of luck around as I
said some of the players uh you know
being fit but if they do that they're
certainly on the right side of the draw
for it yeah mate it's going to be some
Rugby World cap I'm looking forward to
it but let's get back to your career um
the move to Gloucester
why'd you move to Gloucester what was
that all about
opportunity I think me at the time I was
probably I've been up at animal for a
fair amount of time
um and and Gloucester really appealed to
me because
in many ways probably because of where I
grew up in Scotland like a sort of small
Rugby Town and I I sort of fell
Gloucester had that connection with the
town they're really well supported
almost like an old school rugby club in
many ways um and then when I met I'll
explain at the time and he'd been an
expert he was he's a sort of the team
manager at the time and I really sort of
liked you know what I had to say he's a
good rugby man and as soon as I sort of
met him you know to be fair to him and
the south at the time they made a good
impression on me and yeah that was it
just particular opportunity and uh
really sort of had in my mind that I
really wanted to try and get out of
Scotland at some point and go and play
somewhere else and experience some
something different and how'd you find
the English premiership how did that
compare man that was awesome as well
because at the time we were playing in
sort of had a few years well it's now
called the URC to the South African
teams have no joined it but when I was
playing it was just the Italians Welsh
Scottish and Irish but it was good but
like it wasn't too well supported in
terms you know uh you know fan base and
stuff like that certainly us and no we
played inside murrayfield at the time so
you know he'd probably pick up five six
thousand now a game so that was some
tough working and you know when I went
down to Gloucester
um and not not even close like going
away to the way stadiums for you know
glossary bath or Bristol whoever it was
like real you know really well supported
any you know Gloucester home games 14 15
000 sellouts for the most part and just
fantastic atmospheres and I think that
really sort of uh really sort of drives
your sort of performance personally as
well you know you've got to you feel as
though you've got to perform a weekend
week out and you know I definitely
really enjoyed it and certainly helped
me as well make the shed you get so much
energy from the shed don't you man what
a spot the shed man they love it don't
matter they probably love the rugby uh
they know how to get behind their team
uh for sure so you know definitely
definitely bound to be playing for the
gloss stuff right I'm against them when
you're done now yeah and how do you find
uh Laurie Fisher coach I've always been
intrigued by I've heard some good
stories about him in the past and I'm
sure you've got a couple of good ones
the long ultimate the Lord laude is a
good minor like obviously a different
character a man a man to himself uh as
as you probably know I think he's just
one of the great characters in the game
like real sort of technical coach uh but
you know but we're certainly really out
there you know he just loves the game of
rugby up so he loves code uh you know
watches a lot of it uh but real like
passionate about the game
um real technical around the sort of
forwards it was kind of funny I could
use quite Blasio but uh in terms of he's
like yeah I mean I just looked after
after the forwards uh he's like you'll
need to speak to somebody else sort of
impact stuff yeah I'm just you know
whatever the forwards but you boys sort
of crack on at the back there so
throughout your career where you're
always sort of driving the game plans
where you always that sort of player
where you had a big influence on what
the team were running
I did like that side of it um as I sort
of touched on a little bit before and
around that sort of thinking side of the
game always try to you know think about
it and you know be as positive as you
can be I never liked or never wanted to
play in one of their teams that just
kick kick kick all the time but you know
there's a fine balance you know when to
kick when to run and
um you know it's just put in the good
practices and the end of the team and
almost put in a mindset into a team not
so I was you know found the best teams I
was involved with it's almost like a
you know essential everybody's on that
same pagement as I'm sure you know
you'll be finding and coaching stuff as
well it's like it's just a collective
mindset you know in many ways and you
know if I was Captain or one of the game
drivers you know trying to sort of lead
on that and bring other people into that
sort of decision-making process so then
why the move to France and Claremont I
know they love a goal kicking nine over
there so it was they had a big part of
it obviously yeah Euros are on it yeah
Gloucester yeah to be honest
um because I really did enjoy my time
down there but again like having an
announcements opportunity you know and I
think
because probably because of my
competitive nature I had something in
the back of my mind I would love to have
played in France there's been a few
Scottish guys I've done it sort of over
over their career and and I'd probably
spoken to them and asked them you know
about it and and I think because I had
access to it would be able to watch it
on the TV
it was a great spectacle as well and I
suppose I was speaking to too long as
well at the same time as Claremont which
would have been like from a lifestyle
lifestyle perspective I think my wife
was more keen to go to Tulane uh to be
honest with me but like for me
at a time that they were owned by
a guy who was in notoriously fairly
loose shall we say in terms of around
some of the things he was doing and and
I just didn't feel it was like a good
fit for me yeah as a team so I have
absolutely no regrets signing for for
Claremont I talked before about you know
that old she's not old chill but like I
guess the town like getting behind the
the Rugby Club and supporting them and
yeah start martial michelan down there
in Claremont when it's full there's no
bad place to play rugby I would argue
like unbelievable supporters who are
right behind their team and had some
great memories from their email Yeah you
mentioned like um in Gloucester the
crowd being unreal those fans being
noisy but the French the French are a
whole new level
a little bit before in terms of that
Scotland stuff but the match day in
Claremont now you'd like I think we used
to meet up like five or six hours before
kickoff you do a lot of walk through in
the field and then we'd just walk over
to a hotel kind of behind the stadium
and then when I was you know whatever an
hour or an hour 20 minutes before
kickoff he'd always walk over from the
hotel to back to the stadium and by this
point I made like the crowds were they
were there man they were in place like
lying in the streets the French Pond
were going and I just like the
atmosphere just from like the minute you
walked out of the hotel it was like for
a year I've got to get going tonight
because you know these guys that are
going to tell us if we're not on so yeah
we didn't you don't lose too many games
at home
um in France and we had a pretty good
record
um and Claremont yeah and just even
watching um La Rochelle in the weekend
like the crowds that they bring once
they've won the competition it's just
amazing seeing how many people turn up
to you know something like that of a
winning parade man they're almost like
football fans in many senses yeah you
know in terms of you know sorry in a
real sort of cultural
um connection with the team like as you
said like even I was watching a lot of
shell game there and I was just like you
know bloody hell like how good yeah like
like yeah and pumps like the flares
going off the whole the horse you're
buying a lot of showers I said great
place to go and play yeah and you
probably seen some of the celebrations
and stuff down down in the Portland as
well it's like a a quiet little town on
the seaside but you know they come to
come to life for the rugby so they've
got a great thing going there now yeah
incredible so then the last move in your
career to Japan why Japan obviously
you've seen most of the world obviously
never got to Super Rugby but was it just
to tick off one last country and one
more experience
the end's not doing so well at the
minute I'm afraid
all the economy is struggling here but
oh no hold on yeah
um
what brought me to Japan like I never
had a
thing in my mind to say look I want to
play in England France you know Japan
that was never me I don't know I know
tick off companies as such I just
um
I don't know the opportunity I guess
again I was I was in France I was
enjoying France
I had an option to stay not with
Claremont but with a different team in
yeah I think yeah careers are shorten it
and that's probably one that I really
sort of thought listen I've got this
opportunity now you know around the time
it was for two years obviously I've got
kids and stuff at the time so you speak
to your wife you you say Luke shall we
shall we take on this challenge uh
fortunately for me my wife's always been
you know been really great around that
stuff and so she says listen you know
why don't we do it it's a great
opportunity a great life experience and
that was probably the one thing really
in the end is that life experience you
know come and do something different and
then go from there yeah well it's pretty
cool way that you can look back on your
career and you know you experience
living in four different countries
playing professional rugby and some of
the best competitions in the world and
um yeah just hit one hell of a career so
advice for someone who's looking to go
overseas what we would just sort of rank
them in terms of going to the URC
English Premiership French top League or
Japan like give us the pros and cons of
sort of each competition from your
perspective oh
um right okay that's a good question
oh let's start on Japan I guess since
I'm here I think you know once you're
here in Japan I think a great life
experience
um obviously completely different the
rugby is still young and progressing the
way the system works so there's some
frustrations around that but you know
coming with your eyes open uh that's
probably a generalization for for all of
them you know expect it to be different
because it's probably going to be and if
you expect this you know move somewhere
else and it's going to be the same then
you know the other guys that probably
don't last uh you know so Japan's also
made so it's great fun seasons are
shorter and you know it's a great
company with great people I think
yeah if if you're going to like let's
say a France or probably France and
English Premiership will put them
together it's you've got to be like more
more mentally ready I reckon for like
the length and almost the slog of it
satellite salary in France like it's
hard work uh you know weekend we can you
go to win games go in going away from
home where the home team's expected to
win spells especially in France
um long bus trips uh potentially to
games and stuff like that so you prepare
yourself mentally uh to do that try and
speak the language it's definitely in
France like that's big culturally for
them they're sort of they'll put up with
you for a little bit but if you don't
start to try and speak a bit of French
but they'll soon get sick of you oh
really uh yeah yeah you know again
English Premiership probably falls under
the same sort of you know mentally you
gotta turn up physically each week
Etc and I think the big one with the URC
um it's it's probably a younger
competition as well
um since the South African teams have
joined but I think you've got a fact
that in there I guess is like the travel
but once you're there so you know if
you're going across with your family or
whatever you know you're you know over
to early one week you're all over to
South Africa you know down in Wales a
bit of a fair bit too there's there's a
lot of moving Parts
whereas I guess once you're in England
France or Japan you know you're sort of
in country and that's who you're kind of
set so you're gone for a game day but
you're never going for too long you know
right that is great Intel great Intel
for anyone who's looking for an overseas
experience because there's a question I
get asked all the time like which um
where do I think I should go like I'm
young or I'm older what do you think's
the best option for me and um right
you've summed them up beautifully so
what was your favorite one to play in
when you look back on what's your
favorite years of your career
yeah
and not because any other ones have been
bad but yeah yeah just like good club
great competition
good players at the time when I was down
in Claremont and you know whether it's
French guys
foreigners guys like Nick abandoning ice
toyava oh yeah uh he was he's probably
one of the best players I've ever played
with actually he's unbelievable oh wow
yeah man he was he was Unreal if he was
he was if he was fat uh that was Isis
probably struggled with his body a bit
Yeah but yeah when he played for us man
like everybody else was so much more
confident because he was that good
that's true was it um Fitness because of
injuries or Fitness because
um you know just unfit conditioning wise
no he was he struggled with his with his
body aches I think he'd had a few near
sort of hip issues as well so I mean
he's obviously like a you know power
sort of speed player as well so you know
the problems are like that yeah he liked
a good time as well
you two would have got along just well
then
when you look back on your career what
sort of made you the player you you were
you think like obviously you've spoken
about the top two inches but
um you look back on your career how do
you sort of feel about it well I think
I guess my drive my sort of and I'll
drive to to make myself better yeah the
Dollar's probably the big one for me in
a nutshell really it was yeah I wanted I
was competitive but you know I wanted to
be the best version of myself you know
in many ways and and whether I was you
know down in Gloucester and and I think
that
some people can stay at one club and and
I've got real admiration for people who
can do that to keep mentally fresh but
the sort of move really helped me
because you almost have to uh you know
prove yourself again to like a different
Yeah a different peer group a different
group of players people yeah right so
yeah our phones are real beneficial I
don't know what you phoned you know
moving clubs but I found out real
beneficial to me I was the exact same
feels like you've got to sort of earn
that respect again from everyone hey
like you can't just sort of rest on what
you've done in the past and start fresh
mate that's that's a good point but
anyway I've got about a thousand
questions come in for you from the from
the Instagram you're a popular from some
of the kills and kiwi so we'll try and
get through a few of these before we
wrap this up but
um here we go yeah okay why do they call
you Darren
uh I wonder who asked that it could be a
few guys
oh man so
yeah I guess once I've had a couple of
beers mate I I do like to
enjoy myself put a you know as much as I
can so yeah not uh I talked about being
an introvert before so maybe darling's
not so much of an introvert me he likes
to he likes to chat I guess smile on his
face so another couple of beers so an
introvert till he's had a few a few
drinks yeah that's it but so what's
Darren mean though
um it was a name that came out of
Edinburgh it was just some ridiculous at
a time there was uh a couple of guys up
in Edinburgh and I don't even know
actually it was somebody that sorry
there's a couple of people that called
Donna and then eventually just sort of
come to me after another couple of beers
and that was that many sort of grew from
there and nowhere really
how does everyone call you Darren like
uh not well after investment they
probably will
oh it's good stuff oh I love a good
weird nickname okay next one how much
did you chant how much did you charge
Lance for your kicking sessions
[Laughter]
oh this one came from my brother he told
me the story laughing soon
that's a good one
um so Lance Bradley is no the chief exec
to actually done in Gloucester now who
was under the team he was Chief exec of
uh of Mitsubishi who are the the main
title sponsor of Gloucester
um and then Lance you like never played
rugby like straight out of the office
job man he's come to me one day he's
like oh uh Greg I need to I need to like
learn her a kick and I was like what do
you mean you need to learn how to kick
it is that so Tom's out he's playing at
us like charity again darling down in
Gloucester and he's asked me like for a
few picking lessons how old is he oh
it's like yeah I don't know
you know a great businessman yeah he's
literally never picked up at Walmart and
then so the first days come down to the
training grounded in Gloucester and the
boys are like what are you up to and I
was like oh I've got Lance for it I'm
gonna take him kicking and the boys are
like what are you on about it so I've
explained that next minute I'm own I
feel that I can see the boys like
they're all they sort of picking up the
the changing rooms and stuff
oh they're taking a picture of me for a
while for that one but did you teach
them how to kick how did he go oh he
went all right man he knocked the and
kicked a few in the Charlie much I don't
like to watch him later so you don't all
right mate but he was he was pretty kind
to me he was he he was a head of
Mitsubishi he looked after me put it
away that's why he got him to coaching
because he turned a normal office man
into a world-class
uh they're in good you're um The Shining
acts are in good hands next year with
that what a start okay next one give us
your best Laurie Fisher impression you
spoke about him before obviously a great
man
oh man a lot is mate get in the Elvis
Chase connection eliminate numbers what
else did he like killer threat killer
threat that was his big one give me
Irish Chase connection
good Aussie accent himself
there's there's my there's my wild
impression oh man that is good oh Laurie
Fisher Legion okay next one have you
seen Craig Joubert after that Rugby
World Cup quarter final you said he
obviously Sprint off after the game
um have you have you caught up with him
afterwards or
um have you ever had a conversation with
him yeah I mean we did so we I think it
was maybe the the
precedent Six Nations uh
well I'm not sorry it must have been the
Six Nations after yeah clearly
um he came in he was running a touch
against for
Scotland of the island I think it was
over in Dublin and he asked because
Veronica VC was was the head coach at
the time and brown was still the the
coach for the for the Fallen Six Nations
and Veron sort of said to me listen the
crazy Bears asked to come in and uh you
know come and speak to us so uh Verona
myself who went to to speak to me came
and meet us in the hotel with a sort of
chat about it and he sort of said Luke
sorry for I was apologizing for more
sort of running off the field and yeah
and stuff so yeah you know respect him
for that and yeah that's all he can do
but may I tell you one thing He's a
brave man coming in to meet uh to meet
VCS he's a scary customer
yeah oh that is good
um because you're you're apparently
pretty intimidating um to referee as
well what did I see the other day um was
it JP Doyle or one of the refs over
there mentioned that you being the most
intimidating player to ref out of
everyone he's ever Rift where does that
come from no wonder no wonder Juvia ran
off he's scared of you man they all are
yeah he didn't want him he just left
uh I've seen that about GP actually but
man I think he's working for Scottish
rugby so maybe somebody paid him off to
say that about me I don't know but uh
I think over the years again I've I've
definitely mellowed and uh but I just
start like you know well to will to win
push the boundaries and it's funny
because like you know you see it on you
know bloody social media these days in
terms of you know people getting slagged
for speaking of refs and this and that
but what people forget is the guys that
are playing the game are competitors
yeah you know and they put so much
emotional energy of so much energy into
in their games or rugby sometimes you
know things spill over and it's just
part of it and you know nine times out
of ten after the game you you know most
boys will be all good with the ref and
stuff like that so it's just it's part
of the game but I think and most of it's
done with it with enough respect in my
opinion right sounds like a true referee
serial abuser
[Laughter]
that's a good place to go learn um some
respect for some referees isn't it
okay next on what's it like playing the
All Blacks and facing the hakka
fantastic experience obviously it's it's
very unique
um you guys you got the Haka and I think
culturally it's it's obviously a huge
part of of the All Blacks of New Zealand
I think it's yeah it's always felt
really really privileged
um you know to stand in front of it and
really challenged as well I think it's I
think I spoke briefly before about you
know whether it's playing in New Zealand
I think it's in terms of our rugby side
it's it's one of the biggest or the
biggest challenges out there in rugby so
yeah I always felt real privilege to
stand in front of it and and have the
opportunity to test myself against you
know for the most part of the best team
in the world is it intimidating watching
it or is are you just more getting
energy from it or are you actually
watching them thinking oh [__] these
guys are these guys are on
yeah well it's not listen it's not
intimidating but I think it's you can
see you can almost feel the energy but
you can see the energy that you know all
blacks can pick up of it uh you know
because it's you know culturally it's
it's connected uh you know to the Jersey
to the you know to the history of that
Jersey so I think the the obviously it's
a strong part of
or of who they are is as people and as a
team so you know there's definitely an
energy around it and a sort of Aura and
I think even in the stadiums as well I
think it's great when a sort of crowd or
quiet and you can really hear it as well
I think it really adds to the spectacle
oh mate look good answer okay what's
your favorite part about Rugby Union
oh
the people probably man
yeah that's I think there's there's
tough times definitely and there's good
times as well but I think through all my
when you when you think back
and you're probably the same it's a lot
of times you don't remember the games
but you certainly remember the people
the the characters yeah you know whether
or not you know John Hardy or you know
whatever somebody always Springs to mind
so definitely the people for me right
100 and especially someone like you
who's been to so many different teams
and experience so many different
cultures you would have met so many
people and Rugby's such a small world or
Community isn't it you meet people who
know people and um just one big um yeah
sort of community that just you know
basically everyone from one person
removed really yeah definitely okay next
one or most the listeners will be
wanting to know about this one favorite
Night Out Greg laidlaw's favorite Night
Out jeez
oh there's so many to choose from yeah
there's been a couple of good ones over
the years man
I'll talk about having fun with with
Finn now later on
yeah that was one that obviously I don't
know if you've seen that one but I ended
up ended up uh getting caught or well
not caught on video but on video and uh
with tearing my shirt off after we beat
England in uh 2018 after the Calcutta
cup man I was in a bit of a massive to
say the least but there so what actually
happened was what I like there's a team
and it was actually Finn's girlfriend
Emma she's like put it or a story up on
her Instagram or whatever now obviously
everybody's been pretty pretty well on
but it went to bed woke up in the
morning things like you know check and
use Instagram and he said to his message
I oh you better think I've done like you
know Greg's here he's got his [__] or he
looks pretty pissed so she's flipped her
down there but it's been too late it was
gone it's like what Wildfire
um you know the best the best part about
that is I was playing in Claremont at
the time
tonight
the Sunday I was like sore off I was
meant to be flying by the France I think
it biked to Claremont but my flight is
canceled for whatever reason so I was
like oh happy days I'll just chill here
so I flew back on the Monday morning but
the Monday morning I was with Rachel and
the kids and because uh Saturday night
in a Sunday like none of it was in the
papers yeah but then because it was then
Monday morning it was a day later I was
on the front front of the newspaper and
the headline was sharp faced well
obviously my shirts off right on the
shirt face but I'm sort of like and then
the kids Rachel are here and I'm like
sorry I shouldn't uh I sure and the kids
passed all the newspaper stands and the
in the bloody airport trying to get on
the plane back to France yeah that's
crazy
there was one fellow he come up to me in
the airport it was pretty funny he sort
of had the paper folder over and he sort
of slipped her under me he's like you
wouldn't sign that would you so I'm
saying that enough he went
oh mate how did you feel when when that
was going on did you did that actually
absolutely like break you or um was it
just more of a bit more of a laugh or
was it pretty intense when you're going
through it oh man yeah I was I was
pretty nervous because obviously it was
you know captain of the captain of
Scotland at the team and obviously
there's a you're you're definitely a
role model and stuff but I think would
just be in England won the Kolkata cup
so I feel like I was going to be showing
a little bit of leave in there that was
when I was
uh thankfully everybody took it when it
was you know I think we were singing
flying to Scotland and you know had a
fair few anyway but it would sound like
a good night just a normal night for you
mate
okay next one toughest setback of your
career and how did you overcome it
um
I'm not too many injuries which has been
helpful I got I got left over there
Scotland World Cup squad in 2011. oh
yeah um and I was I was obviously a
young girl and I think I'd only been cut
by Scotland at the time uh on a couple
of occasions uh but you know at the time
like I felt as though I was like turning
a house down you know sort of really
sort of coming into my own and and
getting a bit of confidence a bit of
momentum and
and the you know the choice to go in a
different direction you know show us
um different halfbacks uh so I found
that really difficult to take at the
time because I'd I was sort of pushing
through entire team and uh you know
sellers or probably should have been
selected so you know I was a real sort
of you know kicking the teeth for me at
a time
um so I guess it wasn't like a real Lane
in the sand but I think I sort of went
away and I thought right you know how to
how does this sort of thing never never
happen again uh and how do I make sure I
can get into the get into the team going
forward so you know I went away worked
on a few things and you know after that
World Cup that was when I sort of pushed
them to the team so you know hopefully
from the the tough times
as long as you as long as you're landing
and there's always a sort of why behind
it and you know you can you can see the
sort of positives and and take the good
things out of it hopefully
why do you think you didn't have many
injuries was there anything that you did
that you felt like
um helps you not get injured as much
because obviously some guys
um have a brutal run of injuries but
um you obviously were pretty lucky from
that point of view yeah I was right um
oh listen luck it looks a bit to do with
it
um certainly part of it but I was pretty
professional
um you know you know I did like a good
team as well but but only at the right
times and then I think you know that was
are sort of as you get older
and if you want to become a leader you
know you got to say examples as well so
that was something I was real sort of
aware of and around my professionalism
um my preparation you know all the all
the small things of the field that
nobody really sees whether that's you
know your prehab you know we joked about
the gym before but your gym work and all
that sort of stuff so I did take that
seriously as well and really sort of
prepare myself because it's it's a
professional World it wouldn't know me
and you've gotta if you wanna you know
be in that sort of top percentile yeah
you've got to do all that stuff behind
the scenes nice okay two more questions
best player he's ever played with
holy so many yeah oh man
I'm at the same team at the moment as
Israel for love here in Japan
um he's pretty special in terms of like
an athlete and like his ability to end
air uh specifically is something to
behold so he's definitely up there but
you'll just be petting box kicks out for
him like you over there yeah that's him
that's that's 90 of the game plan
um so he definitely opt out about
potentially ice Toyota yeah
he was like
as I said when he was fat man like
entered any touch TV he was a red
Checker like he had it all he could you
know run past kick or floored step and
he was aggressive as well so he had he
had the whole package there so I reckon
if you know a fully ice I reckon we
would probably just get my vote but I've
been lucky enough to play with a lot of
good guys over the years yeah mate
that's interesting obviously um he was
thrown into the all black Jersey at a
young age and never really
um I guess took his opportunity in the
all black um Jersey for whatever reason
but obviously such a special talent and
has gone so well since he's gone over to
France and had some great years for the
blues as well but I'm shame we never
really got to see that on the on the
international stage because he could
have like you said absolutely dominated
the international scene yeah shrimp um
he actually played for New Zealand on uh
uh when I won my first camp for Scotland
as well so yeah which I never knew at
the time but uh looking back here ice
was there he's on the program yeah good
okay last question I see everyone this
one one piece of advice you have for a
woodland listener you've given some goal
kicking advice you've given all sorts of
good advice about this one what are you
gonna give see
oh it's pretty simple but you know
don't give up in terms of
you know if he's got a dream or a focus
point in mind you know whatever you want
to call it you know Chase it down and
like just just don't let it go I think
that was that was me in many ways in
terms of you know briefly talked there
about you know being left out of the
Scotland Squad and we're heading to that
World Cup and you know my ambition was
to play for school and go to World of
Cups so you know I kind of you know I
could have sat back in and almost Let It
Go and said I've not done it or or you
really you know got your teeth go and
Chase it down
you know a lot of my piece of advice you
know don't give it up if you really want
it go and get it and make it happen
right what a piece of advice and what a
coach you're gonna be look being able to
give that sort of advice to to players
every single day mate you're going to be
one of the greatest coaches ever
I don't know about that but we'll see
we'll see how we go hey mate I really
appreciate you coming on the podcast um
giving up your time um true Scottish
legend I don't first time I've met you
but mate it feels like I've known you
for ages for some reason uh you're
someone I feel like
I need to have a few beers with it at
some point in my life and I look forward
to that yeah but looking forward to um
obviously following your coaching career
um followed your rugby career with with
interest and um obviously you're a true
legend of the game so um awesome having
you on the podcast mate no it's been a
pleasure and uh hopefully I can get down
to New Zealand at some point I love to
catch up with Clark in if I do I'll give
you a show with definitely right
absolutely Legend